hello folks welcome to rational science
and we had a
we have a very great day today hopefully
it's probably going to be quick short
today okay uh we're gonna be dealing
with Vector we're going to try to try to
find out what a vector is okay but
before I can get to that uh had a little
incident this week some of you are well
aware of it what happened you know it's
a miracle that you know that I mean I
can transmit today okay because my if I
if it was my other channel I wouldn't be
able to transmit it's blocked okay they
blocked the other one
uh uh what was all that about
it turns out that this what they sent me
from uh the folks the powers that be
okay say your content was removed due to
violation of our community guidelines
well I didn't know I violated any
guidelines I wasn't even aware of it uh
because it's the first time this is just
a warning if it happens again your
channel will be will get a strike and
you won't be able to do things like
upload uh post live stream for one week
okay
and yeah these are the types of notes
that I got from them
okay
let's see I got another note here from
them
I hope I'm still on uh
uh let me know otherwise because I just
got a message from YouTube
so I don't know if they're gonna let me
to talk today okay we'll see we'll see
what happens okay so let me know if if
you can't see me or hear me okay
anyways uh I got another warning I got
several warnings I've got warnings all
over the place and uh this was why I was
warned uh because of medical
misinformation
medical okay thank you please confirm
every now and then because I don't know
if they're gonna let me finish today
anyways uh it's medical misinformation
I'm misinforming people I was not even
aware of it that I was misinforming
anybody it was just outrageous says uh
YouTube is a safe place for all we have
to keep it safe no doubt about it
um it says YouTube does not allow
content that spreads medical
misinformation that contradicts local
Health authorities
that's the I guess the rule the policy
whatever that I violated unknowingly
unwittingly I didn't even know I had
violated anything uh all I did was put a
video that's out there
and it's a video from a conference an
International Conference
okay where the different speakers get to
say what they think openly
and here they treated it like uh you
know Kim Jong
from North Korea they simply censored it
that's how simply simple it is and uh it
wasn't because you know I had uploaded
somebody else's video you know that
wasn't the reason the reason to what you
see there it's that I'm spreading
misinformation I was
so this is this is a really a shock to
me that uh they would go to that extreme
to someone who's not even aware
unwittingly puts up a video and I get
almost a strike there they said it's
just a warning but my other channel is
blocked so I had to protest that because
they say here we're giving you a warning
the warning turned into a strike because
I can't get in there uh some parts of it
I can't get into the studio and I can't
get into my dashboard
okay and this is uh what they're saying
there you can see it says because it's
the first time this is just a warning if
it happens again your channel will get a
strike and you won't be able to do
things like you know upload etc etc okay
uh
thank God they told me all this
uh because maybe I would have
immediately put another video and they
would have you know just given me the
strike without me having a chance to
even you know challenge it and right now
I can't even challenge it on my other
channel because I can't get it to the uh
part of my channel where you're supposed
to do the challenge again
can't get into my studio
okay and uh so this is uh what I have on
that channel now it says your content
was removed due to violation blah blah
blah and it's because it's the first
time it's just a warning no it was more
than a warning I mean I can't get in
there so maybe it's a system I don't
know maybe it's a human I have no idea
so what was all this about
um and I'm gonna have to talk in code
here because I didn't know uh you know
this was such a big deal in fact I pay
very little attention to this because
it's not part of my theory my extension
Theory uh you know disease so I don't I
don't care about it at all okay the only
time I raise the issue of disease is
like to say you know that never happened
like a disease never killed any species
okay that's the way that's the only
reason I I bring in the issue of disease
but uh so I got to talk a little bit in
code here and I hope you can read
between the lines there okay
uh a woman
I guess I can say that because you know
today our pronouns and nouns are
acceptable so you can call it Shia he
and vice versa so I guess I can get away
with this okay a woman spoke at an
International Conference
okay and those of you who did manage the
kids to see the video know what I'm
talking about okay
and what was the the issue the issue was
a Melody uh ailment some kind of poison
out there okay that's what the topic was
about I can't even mention the topic
because I'm afraid to cancel my my my
channel you know so I can't mention the
the word it's a bad word you can talk
about anything today you can talk about
homosexuality about God but you cannot
talk about this
Okay so
I hope you can read between the lines
and she said it's been around this was
what caught my attention for 70 years
and I'm saying oop you know I didn't
know that uh so if it's been around for
70 years well we got a little bit of a
problem because
if that is so and some of the
information that's out there is false
assuming it's true right what this
person is saying well then the
information that you see out there is
false okay
again if it's true that's a big if okay
uh she's been censored I try to locate
her
everywhere and they simply ban this
individual I mean can no longer speak
okay you can't find them you find other
people talking about her right
but not her herself okay uh can't even
mention her name so sorry I can't tell
you her name not here but I'll give you
some clues in a little while uh and
that's I guess how much he is feared
uh I thought she spoke very fluently
very
intelligently okay that's what also
caught my attention and I think that's
the reason she is feared I mean you can
talk about diseases
if nobody believes what you're saying
nobody cares because the way you talk
about it and you know they say well he's
a loony nobody's going to believe in him
uh uh then uh they don't do anything to
you but this person
this person comes across as a knowable
an authoritative authoritative uh person
and so a lot of people might believe
this individual and so if that's the
case then they are afraid of what he
might say okay
and he does talk about Investments and
he mentioned some people you know and
maybe that's what it's all about the
fact that you know there's a bit of
danger out there right
uh but if what this person saying it
destroys everything that you've been
told okay and that's a big if okay I'm
dying about a big if here okay
um so when fellow tells me who saw the
the video he says the following he says
uh I've heard you're you arguing against
Authority in uh uh science many times
yet this gal
uh should be more credible for white
Authority doctor double standards
uh well uh I think this fellow has it
wrong he's got the wrong idea of what
this is all about so let's find out what
this is all about
it's not about Authority it's not about
belief it's about facts
okay
and then people say Bill I thought you
said facts are not part of science that
you don't care about facts
okay so let's clarify that we've got
facts and we got facts okay so let's uh
make sure we understand what the
difference are between facts and facts
we have the facts by mathematical
physicists okay
mathematicians and uh they what they do
is they convert their theories their
explanations and they say that's a fact
it goes from hypothesis according to
them to Theory and from Theory to fact
once everybody votes for it or
I don't know 50 plus one or ninety
percent I have no idea how they
determine facts but they say space time
is a fact uh you know uh quantum
mechanics is a fact they they say they
say it's a fact you can't change it
anymore okay and so here are some
examples you know this is what they're
saying and they turn these uh opinions
you still use into facts they say a part
of gold can be at two places at once for
us your computer wouldn't work or
gravity is geometry the bending of time
that's the reason you know the Earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system it's
in caught in this depression warp time
and we've proven it with gravity probe B
and GPS
so those are theories that the
mathematicians call facts
okay those are not the facts we're
talking about here and we're talking
about some other kind of fact we're
saying look uh this man lying here for
over a month
you know he doesn't breathe he doesn't
move he's dead
that's a fact okay you can't say well
maybe I don't know no that's a fact yay
uh more clearer even we have the chairs
on the left side of the table hopefully
that's a fact you know we're all looking
at the table we see the chair on the
left hand side of the table that's a
fact
okay now you you can argue all you want
you can stand on your head that's a fact
okay and uh
a device was registered at the patent
office
okay you go to the patent office and you
register a device
now that sounds like a fact uh the you
know uh I might tell you you know I
might say uh
um so-and-so went to the patent office
and registered
a patent
and you might say well I I I have no
confirmation of that so it's a fact for
me but not for you
but you can go to the patent office and
here you can see you know the signatures
the paperwork whatever you need there
you say okay it's a fact now for me too
in that sense it's a fact it's affecting
the sense that someone registered
there's a signature there there's a
record etc etc in that sense it's a fact
the fact that it's not a fact is because
you're not aware of the fact but that is
a fact it exists there's a signature
there okay and it's just that you are
you're not convinced of it because you
have not gone to the patent office to
verify it okay but that is a fact
okay so that's a different fact and a
mathematician telling you that his
theory that a particle can be a two
places at once is a fact and that
they've proven it because otherwise
computers wouldn't work that's a
different nonsense kind of fact okay so
let's distinguish fact from fact and
here we're talking about exactly you
know the example I've given here you
know uh here let me show you
this is
what they're saying they're saying you
know uh this song this individual uh
lady
man woman whatever we whatever pronoun
you want to use okay
uh that some of these patents that they
have out there this is what she was
talking about have been around for maybe
50 60 years
okay so if there's a patent out there
on something or something you can verify
and you can say well this guy's lying or
this gal is telling the truth you know
so you can go either way
okay so it's something verifiable in
fact I took the trouble to find out if
it was true or not you know I I went
there to verify to make sure that I'm
comfortable with this issue right
um and this individual this gal he's
saying um the antidote that they
developed the antidote for this poison
for this ailment
before anyone knew about it
so so you here you have the Bubonic
plague right
and it doesn't come until uh what was it
uh 1348 that's when uh the first uh big
uh you know Black Death issue occurred
in Europe
and here you go to the patent office in
1346 two years earlier
and you patent a uh an antidote for the
Black Death
now that's that's a little
irrational a little counterintuitive why
would you patent something for a disease
that doesn't exist
you see the issue that this is what this
lady was Raising okay
and so it's irration with the patent and
and antidote before the poison exists
that's the issue okay
and so yeah it comes down to censorship
they censored this individual uh they're
they're censoring me I mean they're
blocking me right
um
and uh you know here uh these are lies
that are deliberately you can say
they're lies outright law lies that's
one possibility there's another
possibility is that they're uh they have
different version
of that same story
okay
and I do want to say something about
that because this all says oh bill you
believe everything you read out there no
no uh in fact uh the first step is be
skeptic be skeptical okay and I was
cautious
this individual was talking very
straightforward uh sound sounded
knowledgeable
spit out a lot of facts
and I accepted the facts at face value
to understand what it was all about
out of that uh dissertation I reached my
own conclusion that I'm going to
investigate this I want to understand it
myself and not because it has much to do
with Extinction but because of the way
news is handled which is very very
important here
okay that's the issue eventually you're
talking about censorship right and so I
went out there and uh uh looked at the
uh by the way yeah puts all countries on
the level of uh North Korea when they do
that nobody can say that oh we have
freedom over here and they don't have
freedom over there no no if you do what
they did to this individual and then to
me uh now that's no different than North
Korea absolutely none so no one can
point their fingers at anybody else out
there but anyways I want to investigated
it and I said well was there a patent
and yes there were there were patents
not one but many in the last 60 years
there are several patents
big corporations okay so what's the
issue the issue is that there's two
sides to this story and I'm just making
you aware of it you reach your own
conclusions I just want to make you
aware that there are two sides to this
story there's the side this individual
talked about and said look it's been
around
and a patented this two years before it
happened and blah blah blah
okay so I went to see where this news
came from okay this news came from a an
article that was written uh by a group
that analyzed this whole thing and their
conclusion was that there was a
a strip of molecules okay
molecules atoms you know
and this string of molecules
was found in the poison
and they said that's so strange because
why would we find it here and there this
is too much of a coincidence
it doesn't happen in nature
some other people went and made a
counter argument they said well these
people are wrong it is found in nature
automatically you find it in animals
okay and so all I can give you is the
argument and the counter argument the
argument is this doesn't happen by
chance
and the counter argument is
uh uh no it doesn't happen by chance but
it's already in nature
okay so so you got to be careful uh
don't take any sides until you do of uh
deep research on this okay that's all
I'm saying now the fact that this fellow
is this individual censored
does make you wonder why would they go
out of their way to censor okay okay so
all I can say is for those of you who
want to know what I'm talking about here
we see at the bottom okay you can go
there and you'll find that I uploaded it
there okay so you can just click there
and you'll find I put it up there today
you can go to the site and see it for
yourself see what this lady has to say
about this subject okay and I'll leave
you with that but all I'm saying is have
a word of caution for you and that is do
an investigation before you reach your
conclusion when you listen to this
individual you would immediately think
oh okay yeah it's uh it's always been
like that and blah blah blah no don't
stop there keep going look it up okay
um
I can put the name number of the patents
okay also I've got that as well look
them up and a lot of it is uh a lot of
Mumble jumbo you know it's uh the jargon
very high level jargon so if you don't
understand a lot of that you may not
understand the arguments it's not so
easy okay all I can tell you is there
are two sides of the story to this story
and just you know uh have an open mind
in both directions okay and I'll leave
you with that okay okay anyways uh let's
moving on here we have uh this issue we
have um
that uh some countries are trying to get
away from the dollar as much as they can
and gonna they're trying to see if they
can do some calm or some trade out there
without using the dollar and I hope they
don't censor me for this
uh we have Brazil and China recently
struck a deal to settle trade in their
local currencies okay and what they want
to do is bypass the Greenback Indian
Malaysia same thing and then you have uh
Francis is also starting to complete
transactions in the Yuan okay uh
currency experts are literally sounding
like Cassandra but it says uh predicted
that dollars imminent demise on any
number of occasions over the past
Century and you had an observing this
sudden wave of agreements aimed at
sidestepping the dollar they detect a
sort of meaningful action however small
and gradual that was typically missing
in the past so we have a new situation
where some countries are talking about
this uh they're making plans okay and
for many global leaders there are
rationales for taking these measures are
strikingly similar and what are they
they're worried about America's foreign
policy priorities and the fact that it
punishes those who oppose them okay so
this is what it's all about
so uh this is on its way uh a lot of
people say well it's not going to happen
because the dollar is just so widespread
blah blah blah but you know the pound
used to be the currency of the world for
some time until the dollar replaced it
so keep that in mind
just be cautious okay in some countries
say hey you know the fact that these
folks are using that as a weapon is
hurting our economy and so we're going
to take measures and maybe they have no
other choice but to go in that direction
and that creates a parallel coinage or
many coins you know everybody does
business in their own coin or whatever
and if if that happens you know it's
going to diminish the influence of the
dollar okay
okay so here's a another view of that
says the bricks block you know there you
have Brazil Russia India China and South
Africa is becoming an increasingly
significant alliance against the West in
the wake of Putin's War the alliance is
set to become much more geopolitically
uh geopolitical heavyweight a further 18
Nations have expressed interest in
joining so you can see that this might
be growing I don't know if it's going to
happen or not but uh there's always a
starting point and that seems to be the
case here right in addition to expanding
its membership the alliance is also
discussing plans to introduce a
cross-border currency for brics
countries it's been driven by Russian
China and specifically by the need to
try and find these alternative spaces
for Commerce that are outside of Western
norms and particularly Western sanctions
okay a lot of countries are becoming
aware of the United States is using that
as
um
to as punishment and to get their way
and they don't like it and so it might
be a double-edged sword to do what the
United States did to Russia and just
creates a precedent that other countries
say oh I don't want that happening you
must so why don't we take some measures
in advance
and I think that's where they're at
right now they're in discussions only
okay and I think it's very unlikely that
it's going to happen in a very short uh
time that countries switch to some other
currency or at least some parallel
agreements uh the dollar is very strong
in the world but just keep that in mind
there's always a starting point this is
the ABC and sometimes you reach XYZ okay
in another matter here we have the nukes
uh says amid the crisis triggered by the
Ukraine conflict President Vladimir
Putin announced in February that Russia
was suspending participation in the new
start treaty an agreement signed in 210
2010 that limits the number of Russian
and U.S deployed strategic nuclear
warheads Moscow and Washington
controlled 90 of the world's nuclear
weapons and Moscow would only return to
a nuclear arms reduction treaty if
Washington abandons its hostile stance
which the United States is not about to
do
in the short term so for the short term
there's no agreement no start and no
start means that you know everybody gets
to do their own little secret in uh
developments you know uh tests whatever
they do
uh creates a more dangerous World
especially when they're at war in one
place and maybe we start another War
somewhere else in the Pacific you know
um
not very good for Humanity for
the powers that be not to be friendly
with each other you would think that uh
the opposite would be nice that
everybody you know picks up the red
phone and starts talking and say okay
Joe don't worry about it let's drink
some vodka or champagne or whiskey or
whatever and get it over with and
we reach an agreement you know that's
not happening right now they don't seem
to be on friendly terms now there's a
lot of people out there some conspiracy
theorists you know and they'll say that
all this is talked about in secret but
they do indeed shake hands personally I
don't believe in that conspiracy theory
I don't believe that
Putin and Biden are kissing each other
you know and having fun while the world
suffers I don't think that's happening I
think this is for Real okay I think the
uh navies are moving around the world
they're all doing their own thing
they're all trying to gain influence and
we're headed to a bipolar world we where
we have the East versus West essentially
that's what's happening and this is a
little different than what happened with
Persia or Greece or uh Rome you know
this is a totally different story
because now we're talking about the
entire planet
okay uh it's a closed system right now
before it wasn't a closed system because
there was room for expansion new tribes
new new
um uh countries you could say that would
uh emerge that's not the case now this
is the end uh this is end game kind of
stuff okay
so yeah I think that uh when not if but
when the world collapses meaning when
humans become extinct
uh nukes will probably be part of the
fireworks okay I'm almost sure about
that now I don't think there's enough
nukes to blow the whole planet out uh
there's enough nukes maybe to destroy
the other guy's silos that's one issue
and the other one is they'll destroy
maybe a few cities
but then um the issue as far as I'm
concerned is the destruction of the
global economy we will not recover from
that okay and that's that's my argument
on that
okay uh here's one individual he says uh
you said he collapsed into food chain
and it collapsed in genetic diversity
yeah those are two different mechanisms
okay are you saying that we're going the
way of the gross Michelle well uh
apparently there he said there's this
banana that went away because uh lack of
genetic diversity and that there's
another banana that replaced this one
okay if there's little genetic diversity
to work with the introduction of a
sudden shocking stressor could
potentially wipe out uh wipe us all out
yeah uh and again that's not the theory
you propose here okay this is why for
example the uh tassy tiger you know the
Tasmanian Tiger went extinct because
they were so inbred that they could not
adapt to all the hunting
uh well I don't think that's the reason
the poor old taxi went away okay is this
your theory no uh absolutely now we need
to understand what I'm proposing here
and what I'm proposing here is not
genetic diversity I'm saying that
genetic diversity is happening you know
we're losing genetic diversity okay
we're all clones and a reason we know
that we're clones is we matched our
genetic diversity against uh chimps and
a troop of chimps you know out there in
Africa has more genetic diversity than
the entire human race than eight billion
people
and you say how can that possibly be
here we have all these individuals each
one has mutations every day we should
have a lot of the genetic diversity we
don't
compared to chimps in a troop maybe a
hundred monkeys there you know they have
more genetic diversity among them than
the entire human race of 8 billion
people I hope that sinks in it uh has to
make you think a little bit right okay
so this is what we're proposing here
okay we're saying the following there's
two mechanism of Extinction as far as
this site is concerned one is a
background Extinction the other one is
in a mass extinction background is a
demographic a population pyramid
overturn the other one is an ecological
pyramid overturn you know you have all
these trophic levels okay okay so what
are we talking about we're saying that
um the first one is after millions of
years plants
um lose their genetic diversity okay and
they can't uh
radiate anymore because there are no new
niches to conquer and Mother Nature has
lost uh you know doesn't have in the
magic wand anymore uh gifts to give
these plants so they reach kind of like
the end of the line they they can't
diversify anymore and they've reached
their full potential for for that order
or for that family or for that species
and that happens also to animals animals
you know you have a species they uh
reproduce at the beginning it expands
you know uh greatly especially it's
genetic diversity and but at some point
it turns the corner and the curve starts
coming down all the way to Extinction
it's a long curve but it's always a
downward slanted curve and why is that
because you have bottlenecks and you
have uh Founders effects and those
trunk that was overrule the immune
periodical mutations that these plants
have or animals it doesn't matter if
it's plant or animal the mechanism is
the same okay that's a different
mechanism than we have for
um the overturning of the ecological
pyramid which is what causes a mass
extinction mass extinction is a sudden
Extinction
of entire families or orders whereas the
uh population pyramid overturned is uh
species specific okay so the background
Extinction explains how one species dies
the other one explains how many species
die suddenly two different mechanisms
what is the mechanism the mechanism is
that food disappears gradually and more
towards the end because of the
demographic overturning of uh of the
Pyramid of plants
animals who are stuck to those plants
find fewer and fewer plants the island
shrinks the forest shrink the jungle
shrink right they find pure food but it
turns out that they've expanded in
numbers
at the same time that the food sources
are disappearing okay and so what
happens at some point you know they
don't have enough food to eat
and at some point they collapse the
whole system collapses and it involves
orders it involves many families of
species that depend on the same sources
of food so in a relatively short period
of time maybe of a thousand years uh
they all die a whole order disappears
what has disappeared a food chain
because what disappears first are the
herbivores because their food sources
disappear and right behind them are the
carnivores that's more or less the
situation it happens on land in ear and
in the sea okay so it's Universal so
that's the mechanism that we propose how
is man gonna die he's not going to die
in a population pyramid overturn not
going to die because the um genetic
diversity has disappeared among humans
if we're going to die we're gonna die in
a mass extinction we're going to die
suddenly why because food disappears
food disappears why because someone
produces it today and it ain't you
that's the problem someone brings it
with a Golden Spoon puts it in your
mouth okay that's why you are able to
live one more day and all we have to do
is uh get rid of money
and then the producer doesn't have any
reason to produce it package it and
transporter doesn't have to transport it
to you put it on the shelves for you and
you're on your own at that point okay so
once money disappears food disappears
why will money disappear because our
global economy cannot expand forever
that's the the summary for that okay so
you cannot have the global economy just
expand Forever at some point it's going
to stop expanding when it does not if
but when it does
money will be no more nobody will accept
money of any kind any more than you
except Argentine pesos or Vietnamese
whatever they're called or whatever all
that money is you know that's just Paper
Money numbers in the computer you know
nobody cares about those uh right now we
give it importance because we can do
something with that money but in the
future when no one accepts it you will
not receive it either and at that point
we're all dead
okay so that's in a nutshell the story
okay so let's move on to our uh subject
for today which are vectors okay here we
had a couple of people who can put us on
the right track and they started
criticizing or giving their ideas about
what a number is remember we covered
number and then number line and the
vectors we're going to say are very much
related to those okay basically the
mathematical vectors not so the physical
vectors okay so uh one fellow says the
following says a number isn't the count
which is what we said here okay A number
is the symbol or word
absolutely not that's called the numeral
okay number is not a numeral the numeral
there you see the definition that's not
my definition by the way that comes from
the establishment okay a figure symbol
or group of figures number line
or symbols denoting a number
okay so the numeral is the
hieroglyphic that you put the little
drawing that you put in on paper or
wherever okay that symbol and that is
the numeral
what does it represent it represents a
number what is number the verb to count
it's a verb yeah as you can see it down
there at the bottom okay
counting okay uh five is the numeral
okay numeral five represents number
the problem here is that sometimes we
say the number five
we should be using the word numerals say
the numeral five okay but we're
referring to the quantity meaning what
does the five represent and we call that
a number but we say the number five and
that's where people get confused now we
should say the numeral five which
represents Counting you counted five
times you know you moved your arm back
and forth and said one two three four
five okay that's what it stands for
because we have another gentleman here
who brought up an issue okay anyways the
numeral five is the waving of the hand
up and down that's what it is how many
times I don't know depending on what
number you're what numeral you're
talking about
okay so that's uh the difference between
a numeral and a number okay let's see if
we can get that straight here we have
another gentleman he's got the following
says to count as an action yes
absolutely right if you don't count then
you haven't counted no absolutely wrong
I say Joey could have run
did you understand what I just said well
do you understand the meaning when I say
run does Joey have to run do I have to
run no I just need to understand the
word run okay and not everybody in the
world has to run in order to talk about
the word run uh certainly a person who's
uh quadriplegic might not be able to run
okay so but hopefully they can
understand the word run what the word
run means we are distinguishing between
operations and County no absolutely not
that's not what we're doing we are
defining the word number okay let's see
if you can concentrate on that we are
distinguishing between actual counting
and the meaning of the verb to count
okay so you don't have to actually count
you just have to understand the meaning
of the verb to count what does to count
mean doesn't mean you're going to count
just to say oh I want to understand the
word to count so I'm going to count now
you don't have to count you just have to
understand word to count
one billion can be said and a hand
weighed yeah is that what one billion is
conceptually yes that's what it is
conceptually that's what you did one
billion is to count until you say one
billion no absolutely now you don't have
to count we don't all have to count to
one billion to understand what the term
1 billion or the symbol one followed by
nine zeros means okay one billion means
that the numeral one followed by nine
zero stands for hand waving to a billion
okay in fact there was one fellow and
someone mentioned it so I looked it up
and he's right it says Jeremy Harper is
an American entrant in the Guinness Book
of World Records for County allowed to
one million live streaming the entire
process which took what 89 days so the
guy uh went to sleep woke up and kept
counting okay and took 89 days and he
began on June 18th okay and ended up in
September right his million count
website and firm were taken down some
months later during the count he neither
left his home Etc et cetera Etc okay so
someone apparently did count to one
million uh it took him 89 days I doubt
anybody has ever count to one billion
okay so does that mean we don't know
what one billion is because nobody has
ever counted to 1 billion no we say that
one followed by nine zeros represents
the moving of your finger one billion
times that's what it represents you have
to understand the numeral the symbol
that represents
uh Counting
okay and again you can't count to half
you can't count to three quarters you
can only count integers one two three
four five six and so on okay you can
only count integers you can't count to
zero okay can't count zero Apples
because zero apples is the same as zero
trees zero elephants okay so we don't
count to zero
so zero is not a number uh according to
that definition and again you have all
these negative numbers those are not
numbers okay because those aren't
operations performed on numerals which
represent numbers which are County all
right we got that
okay so here we have um another uh
fellow he says the following I'm not
sure if it's Sameer says time is a
four-dimensional locational variable
uh-huh the hypercube is geometrical
fourth dimension x y z plus time is x y
z t uh-huh
well we had a problem because uh I said
the other day that time is a number line
and this one says it's a dimension
and today we're going to argue that time
is actually a vector
but for this we need to Define these and
what what do these words mean
and again we have to look at uh the
definitions of math
and the definitions of physics okay so
under the definition of physics not even
a vector or or a uh Dimension it's a
number line
but if we're going to go with the
definition of mathematics
then time is a vector not a dimension
okay so that's the argument and here you
can see you have uh x y z
let's call it length width and height
those are the three dimensions right the
names of the dimensions unless you have
some other name and those are standard
okay those are dimensions at least to
physics
what they are in math I don't know what
they're what they call these three
dimensions I don't know we call them
length width and height in physics but
time is not a dimension and you can see
why uh from his example he's saying look
this is the hypercube and that's a
four-dimensional object and it's a XYZ
plus p t meaning time right there you
see time in green
what are we talking about we're saying
that this Cube expands and becomes a
bigger Cube that's that's what the
static image represents in other words
the green lines that go from corner to
corner you know from the small cube to
The Big Cube that's uh an illustration
that's depicting an expansion of the
cube in
freedom in three directions three
directions that we all know about length
width and height okay so it's expanding
okay that's what it is that's what the
green line represents now that sounds
like a vector to me because that's what
uh we've always identified vectors with
uh mathematical vectors by the way okay
so here it is okay here you see it this
is the definition of vector okay this is
out of the Wikipedia you can find it
anywhere else as well Vector a geometric
object okay and you can see it's an
object it looks like a line with an
arrow at the end right that has
magnitude or length it says and
Direction
represented by a directed line segment
not a line but a line segment the
difference is line is in the religion of
math it's a
infinite has no endpoints and a segment
does okay
graphically as an arrow connecting an
initial point a with a terminal point B
so you can see it starts at a and it's
indicating motion okay magnitude and
direction direction well only because
it's got motion okay vectors can be
added to other vectors well we don't add
vectors in physics but they do
apparently whatever vectors are in uh
math they do seem to add them and the
only reason they can add them is that
they represent magnitude but what are
they what is this Vector uh showing the
blue one there it's showing what we're
seeing with time on the left hand side
it shows it's showing that there is
motion okay if you put the a where the
uh one corner of the small box is and
you put B where the uh corner of the big
box is you can see what's happened
there's been motion from A to B
so time is not really a dimension
because dimensions are only x y z
meaning left width and height unless
there's another name for them I don't
know maybe math has some name for them
that we are not aware of but time cannot
be a dimension it's more like a vector
because they're talking about Motion in
this case going from A to B and in the
case of the Tesseract or hypercube it's
happening
um radially it's happening all around
okay this thing is expanding uh in every
direction
okay so I hope we got that there's a you
know there's a bigger problem also with
the um with the Tesseract and it's uh
you can see not only is it expanding
okay that's the first thing you have to
keep in mind but it turns out that you
will see out there that they rotate the
they'll they'll show you the Tesseract
rotating okay so now we're rotating time
I hope that sinks in your rotating time
here's an illustration of what I'm
talking about here's the hypercube or
Tesseract okay you see it
what is a test right Tesseract is a
little Cube that expands and becomes a
big Cube that's what the yellow uh boxes
are show goes from a small cube to a big
Cube okay so they illustrate this whole
movie
in a single image a static image and
they say okay look it's expanded and so
we started out with a little Cube the
arrows the vectors pointing outwards
showing that the corners are growing in
in size you know the everything's
expanding like if it were a balloon and
it makes us bigger Cube and they call
that whole shebang a tisserang they say
it's an object
well we understand the object it's just
a two nested cubes that object we
understand none of that is four
dimensional
okay that's just a nested Cube one Cube
inside another that's all it is but what
it represents is what you have to
understand what you're staring at is not
a still image which you're staring at is
a movie
of a box expanding okay that's what a
tesseract is
but they do something worse and when you
see that on the bottom left-hand side
there the white ones
uh
the way they create every image here
because they're going to rotate this
Cube first the cube has to expand
you take a snapshot of that final Cube
that's one frame of the movie now the
this thing rotates a little bit okay now
but it's already small again now that
one expands and
now you take a snapshot of that one and
so you have this movie of movies okay
you have a movie of a box that's
expanding and then you have a movie of
that motion being rotated so you're
rotating time whenever you rotate a test
rack scary stuff okay I can only
comprehend it after 10 beers otherwise
you can't figure this out okay
so yeah very scary stuff
so yeah so the question is what is time
is time a dimension or is it a vector
you know and what is the difference well
you know uh the vector is again motion
from A to B
and that's what time is you know because
they're looking at magnitude and motion
and that's a vector so why do they say
it's Dimension are they saying that
dimensions and vectors are the same
you know Dimension is defined as a
coordinate as a number of coordinates
number of numbers because a coordinate
is a number
that's how when a vector is defined as
in mathematics it's defined as magnitude
and Direction the problem with that you
cannot uh
blend you cannot merge
you cannot reconcile
okay magnitude with erection one has
nothing to do with the other
magnitude belongs to math
direction is a concept that belongs
exclusively to physics mathematics has
no use for Direction
you know you don't add directions
East plus East what does that give you
bigger East
you know North Plus North left plus left
forward plus forward gives you more
forward you know you don't add
directions okay
so that's that's the big issue the issue
is that you cannot blend what they're
saying uh Vector being magnitude and
direction
okay it's either magnitude or this
direction so number is to count okay we
got that number uh numeral what was the
numeral numeral as the symbol you used
to represent the verb to count how many
how many counts you made okay number
line it's uh essentially uh you know uh
a bunch of numbers that's all it is
do they fall on the line no you can't
put numbers on a line it makes no sense
okay to say oh they're on the same line
so you know like you see there one two
three four five it makes no sense that's
just put in there so that it's nice to
the Eyes by saying okay the two follows
one okay I understand that it's bigger
than the one and the three is bigger
than the two and so we're going to put
some kind of direction to make it easy
on the eyes
but you know when you're counting two
three four five you know there is no
Direction
number two doesn't uh fall eastwards of
the number five or northwards or
westwards of the number five or left and
right you know whatever coordinate
system you use out there whatever uh you
know lines you use out there to
represent location there is no location
for numbers so you gotta say the number
two is on the right hand side of the
five it makes no sense so number line it
has no Direction only has numbers okay
and that's the scientific definition a
bunch of numbers okay that's the
scientific definition of number line
take it from me okay a bunch of numbers
has no Direction no orthogonality those
two uh qualitative
um properties parameters whatever
they belong exclusively to physics they
don't belong to math at all math has no
use for direction or for orthogonality
no use whatsoever and by orthogonality I
don't mean 90 degree angle no no that's
not what we mean orthionality means that
you put the plumb bob so that it points
to the Center of the Earth and you see
the Horizon we call that orthogonal now
if you want to put 90 degrees you want
to put 100 degrees there you have your
own
system of angles you know your own
angular degrees hey go ahead embed your
own system no problem it can be 100 180
500 use whatever numbers you want
but uh perpendicularity orthogonality
just means that one is like this the
other one is horizontal one is vertical
versus the other okay that's all it
means in physics okay one is
perpendicular to the other means it's
when it's vertical the other one is
horizontal okay so number line only has
magnitude
mathematicians confuse the number line
with Dimensions coordinates and vectors
and there you can see what's happening
you know you have these magnitudes one
through five whatever okay that's got
nothing to do with physics physics we
have liquid and height that's the
dimensions okay it's got nothing to do
with the coordinate system numbers tick
marks location of a point within that
group you know within those coordinates
as they call them they're all number
lines one number line is pointed upwards
the other number line is going sideway
they call this a coordinate system
no that's not coordinate those are
number lines not coordinates coordinates
are
um what is it uh longitude altitude and
elevation those are coordinates not not
the elevation um
uh what is it
altitude uh longitude and radius radius
no or the other one
altitude longitude and latitude those
are the three okay but uh nothing to do
with number lines you don't need to have
values for any of those uh qualitative
uh coordinates okay
okay so here we have a little bit of a
summary for all this we have uh what's a
vector in math okay this is the
mathematical Vector not the one of
physics magnitude and direction
that seems to be a number line because
number line is magnitude and Direction
that's all it has magnitude but not
Direction
Direction belongs to the physics you
can't depict number line with a line
makes no sense to depict a number line
with a line again you cannot say that
the number three is to the left or the
right of the number six you can put them
any way you want because it has nothing
to do with Direction okay we
artificially put them in a certain
direction so that people say oh it's an
organized manner four follows three
which follows two which follows one
we don't care about that in physics
physic makes no sense to say that okay
okay line belongs exclusively to physics
because it's an object and math has no
use for objects okay now you have
direction again it becomes belongs
exclusively to physics
math has no use for direction we do not
add or subtract directions East from
East subtract s West from East yes I
don't know
uh number nine belongs exclusively to
math
not the physics okay and uh whereas the
dimensions coordinates and vectors you
know they belong exclusively to physics
what are dimensions length and height
and coordinates uh see if I can still
remember altitude longitude and
um is it latitude
and what are three vectors again there's
only three of them there's only three
perpendicular directions in which you
can move and that's what vectors are
motion
and from a given point reference point
you can only move in three perpendicular
directions okay and one is
um
death the other one is
breath and the other one is elevation so
those are the three vectors have to do
solely with physics okay they have
nothing at all to do with math number
lines numbers ticks and direction as or
magnitude as they say right okay so they
invented mathematical physics
what is mathematical physics
mathematical physics is an attempt to
merge numbers with objects
and and the first religion was geometry
okay geometry was the first one that
tried to put numbers or explain or
describe really in terms of numbers uh
objects especially angles and lines and
points and all that stuff they started
putting numbers so the points became
numbers they put many points they call
that a number line a line because what
is a line made of points right
you figure that out right and then uh
planes are made of lines also points and
solids are made of many planes which are
made of lines which are made of points
and what do they do they started putting
numbers to all that because they wanted
to see quantitative relationships
especially between angles and that whole
thing in a trig and geometry all that
stuff that was our first religion
because we started putting numbers to
objects
and they're incompatible
and numbers you can do all the equations
you want that belongs to math
the object
and relations you don't need to have
quantitative relations you can have
qualitative relationships okay which is
all that mother nature understands and
those belong exclusively to physics so
yeah math and physics can never merge
math is not the language of physics
never will be okay and that's how we're
in the big mess that we are today the
fact that they created this religion
known as mathematical physics it's an
attempt to merge physics uh objects
right with numbers and that's that's how
we ended up with black holes and big
bang and all this nonsense we have today
okay so here's a corollary for all that
says uh Dimension is defined as the
number of numbers
they call it the number of coordinates
what is a coordinate a number so it's a
number of numbers that's the scientific
definition for mathematical physics for
the word Dimension okay uh so again
that's got to do solely with math okay
vectors defined as magnitude and
direction
okay even though uh the math has no
purpose for Direction
mathematicians allege that time has
magnitude and Direction okay so if time
has magnitude and Direction which is
what Vector has magnitude and Direction
you know then uh yeah pursuant to their
own definition time is a vector and not
a dimension
okay so when they say that there's
something called four dimensional space
time
you know ask them which dimensions are
those length width and height
and uh and then you have the dimension
of uh time now time if anything is a
vector you can say it's a three in one
at Best But it turns out length width
and height are not the dimensions
they're talking about in fact they
confuse them all the time they put
length together with altitude which is a
coordinate and length is a or width you
know any of those
those are uh Dimensions so they mix
Dimensions with coordinates uh with
Vector they call them depth or breath
they don't care they use all these words
interchangeably because they're not
talking about physics they're talking
about number lines
and they just make the mistake of saying
oh this is a vector so uh I'm gonna call
this one depth and that one's a
coordinate and so I'll call it altitude
and the other one is a dimension and
I'll call it width
and then they mix them up and they don't
care and then they can put time in there
because for them it's all just number
lines none of these have anything to do
with Dimensions coordinates or vectors
okay so I hope you learned what a vector
is today
okay one question a fellow said uh here
he erased he says uh
this is factorially more ropes there
there are factorially more ropes than
atoms because we're saying that all
atoms are physically interconnected okay
it's an interconnected Universe we're
not connected by energy we're not
connected by
um Force we're not connected by mass
we're not connected by fields
because all those are mathematical
Concepts quantitative Concepts more
specifically no
um atoms are connected physically that's
what we propose here and he says we'll
hold it but you have more ropes and
atoms yeah in fact there you see there's
this uh system here eight atoms there
you can see them and they're connected
by 28 ropes
okay so the question is the front
because see they say well you know you
can't fit too many ropes in there
because it's there's no space for them
well space is that black stuff that you
see between all these atoms do you see
any black stuff there do you see that
any uh rope is pushing the other one
aside
no obviously a space is what uh provides
Contour therefore shape to each one of
those ropes each one of those connectors
okay so no I don't care how many you can
put a gazillion in there in that same
space and uh there will be space between
any two ropes that are not on the same
axis
okay so it's a non-issue this issue that
people raise oh so many ropes yeah
there's lots of ropes there's a lot of
atoms also you want to count how many
atoms are in the universe uh what would
you say no it's impossible you can't
have so many atoms in the universe
well just in the sun alone how many
atoms do we have solar system the Earth
you just in your body how many atoms are
you made of trillions
can you imagine how many atoms there are
in the universe
and people say well no it can't be it's
that's I can't count that for
yeah no kidding and so what does that
have to do what does quantity have to do
with anything especially if space is
nothing
what do we mean by nothing nothing does
not mean the absence of something no
nothing means it has no shape it's the
opposite of that which has shape which
are the some things okay so it has no
shape
it's not infinite and it's not finite it
simply has no shape if it if it had
shape then you could say well it's a
finite
but if it's infinite you know what do
you mean by that you mean that is that
you can travel as far as you want you
won't find a wall
is that what you mean by that what does
that mean does that mean you just need
to travel a little farther
because if you travel a little farther
and find a wall it's fine that
that's all you're saying you're saying
that no matter how far you tremble you
won't find a wall we'll just travel
farther that's all I can tell you just
keep traveling it's like parallel lines
you know they Define them as lines that
don't meet at Infinity well I don't know
travel to infinity and tell me okay so
these are irrational definitions no if
space is a physical object it has shape
and it has it's finite and there's no
such thing as an infinite object so
either it has shape or a don't
black or white okay that's the way it is
and if it has shape it's an object if it
doesn't have shave it's called space
so space has all the space you want okay
you know you want to put a gazillion
more atoms in the universe if you could
no problem space can handle it because
space is nothing
okay space gives you all the space you
need okay and people don't understand
that okay they say no no you can't fit
so many atoms in the universe because it
would uh saturate space
is nothing so you're not saturating
anything
okay with that we'll